at the olympic games many events have
several rounds of competition one of
these is the men's 100 meter backstroke
the upper dot plot shows the times and
seconds of the top eight finishers in
the semi-final round at the 2012
olympics in the lower dot the lower dot
plot shows the times of the same eight
swimmers but in the final round
which piece of which pieces of
information can be gathered from these
dot plots in the semi-final round we see
that these are the eight times of the
eight swimmers we see three swimmers
finished in exactly 53.5 seconds one fin
one swimmer finished in 53.7
seconds right here and one swimmer right
over here finished in
52. or or 52.7 seconds so we can we can
think about similar things for each of
these dots now in the final round one
swimmer here went much much much faster
so this is in 52.2
seconds while this swimmer right over
here went slower we don't know which dot
he was up here but regardless of which
dot he was up here
this dot took more time than all of
these dots so his time definitely got
worse and this is at
53.678 seconds 53.8 seconds so let's
let's look at the the statements and see
which of these apply
the swimmers had faster times on average
in the finals in the finals is this true
faster times on average in the finals so
if we look at the finals right over here
we could take each of these times add
them up and then divide by 8 the number
of times we have but let's see if we can
get an intuition for where this is
because we're really just comparing
we're comparing these two these two
plots or these two distributions we
could say
and so let's see if we if we if all the
data was these three points and these
three points we could kind of find we
could intuit that the the mean would be
right around there it would be around
53.2 or 53.3 seconds right around there
and then we have this point and at this
point if you just found the mean of that
point at that point so halfway between
that point and that point would get you
right around there so those two the mean
of those two points would bring down the
mean a little bit so maybe you know once
again i'm not figuring out the exact
number but maybe it would be around
53.2 53.1 or 53.2 seconds so that's my
kind of in my intuition for the mean of
the final round and now let's think
about the mean of the semifinal round so
if you just look at if you just look at
let's just look at these bottom five
dots
if you find the mean you could intuit
would be maybe right around someplace
around here pretty close to around
53.53 point what is that 53.3 seconds
and then you have all these other ones
that are at 53.5 and 53.3 which will
bring the mean even higher so i think
it's fair to say that the mean and the
final round and the time
is less than the mean up here and you
could calculate it yourself but i'm just
trying to look at the distributions and
get an intuition here at least in this
case it looks pretty clear that the
swimmers had a faster times on average
in the finals it took them less time
one of the swimmers was disqualified
from the finals well that's not true we
have eight swimmers in the semifinal
round and we have eight swimmers in the
final round so that one's not true
the times in the finals vary noticeably
more than the times in the semifinals
that does look to be true we see in the
semifinals a lot of the times we're
clumped up right around here at
53.3 seconds and 53.5 seconds the high
the high time is it as high as this time
the low time isn't as low there so the
final round is definitely definitely
they vary noticeably more
individually the swimmers all swam
faster in the finals than they did in
the semifinals well that's not true
whoever this was they clearly they were
one of these data points up here this
data point took more time than all of
these data points so this represents
someone who took more time in the finals
than they did in the semi-finals
and we got it right